Auroras are spectacular
These dancing lights visit the polar skies when charged
particles strike the Earth’s upper atmosphere--
causing the atoms and molecules there
to glow in a variety of colors
Now, there’s a new dancer in town --
a thin, purple arc named Steve.
The phenomenon was first spotted by citizen scientists
observing the aurora.
In addition to its unusual color,
Steve also stood out based on its location:
it appeared closer to the equator than other auroras, which are
which are typically spotted at latitudes
between 65 & 80 degrees.
The regions of the atmosphere where these light shows
normally occur form a large oval
over each magnetic pole of the Earth.
During times of increased solar activity,
these ovals broaden, moving toward the equator.
This feature, dubbed “Steve” by citizen photographers
who were surprised when it just kept showing up
in the skies over southern Canada,
was a narrow, purple line in the night sky.
Citizen photographers have captured hundreds
of images of Steve over the last few years,
usually during times of increased auroral activity.
In July 2016,
the European Space Agency’s Swarm-A satellite
flew over Steve, revealing
that a previously known phenomenon called
“subauroral ion drift”, or SAID,
may explain its unusual properties.
SAIDs are narrow regions of charged particles
moving rapidly to the west, sometimes at speeds
exceeding 5 kilometers per second
Researchers believe that Steve is simply
an optical manifestation of a SAID, a phenomenon
that’s been measured before but never seen.
Thanks to satellite data,
and observations from citizen scientists,
researchers now have a better understanding
of this atmospheric feature.
In a nod to its original informal name,
scientists
have suggested that it be called a
“Strong Thermal Emission Velocity Enhancement,”
otherwise known as STEVE
The discovery of STEVE helps highlight the importance
of citizen science and the many ways in which
professional scientists and enthusiastic amateurs
can work together.